a zoo in Japan is being overrun by women
visitors who want to get a glimpse of
the hunky gorilla named Shabani that's
right he's become an internet sensation
thanks to his brooding good looks and
the poses he does when his photo is
taken I'm not making this up here's a
picture of Shabani women go nuts here he
is again look at this guy and here's one
more he's playing Evelyn he is like a
gorilla supermodel it's just amazing
Andy Andy
[Music]
[Applause]
Andy what oh I'm sorry Kona and I just I
mean I can't take my eyes off that sexy
gorilla you know what I mean Conan sorry
Andy I was just distracted by that sexy
rooster and the wife-beater tea I I
don't know what happened to Andy I Andy
Andy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
any snapback I'm sorry it's just a
lobster wearing a fedora a tiny little
Fedora like God oh and now the bombas
doing it's ridiculous
[Applause]
well that's our take on what's happening
with the zoo gorillas hey thanks for
watching be sure to click subscribe to
see even more great Conan clips you may
now return to your pirated movies and
creepy Japanese pornography